(dramatic orchestral music)
- Standing at 28 feet and
weighing in at five tons,
the LW-Mononofu is a life-sized robot
that was built by one man.
Masaaki works as an
engineer at Sakakibara,
a company that develops
machines for agriculture.
But they also make
life-sized robots that people
can operate for fun, and Masaaki,
along with his colleagues,
have built them all.
(roaring)
So when Masaaki's job
tasked him with creating
a robot to help promote
the company, he referenced
one of his favorite
animes as a kid, right?
- But just building the robot
wasn't enough for Masaaki.
He wanted something that
was bigger and better
than his previous models.
He poured his heart and soul into making
the LW-Mononofu fully operational.
It can move its arms,
its legs, it has a gun
that shoots sponge balls.
It's his greatest creation yet.